alors qu'est-ce qui vous amène à Hong
Kong je suis le commandant d'un énorme
PbO mon ami de petite taille ici présent
est agent de voyage il déch'ant pas du
tout une tête de command voulez la
vérité on est tous les de AG
secr on a des vies
géniales tu regard quoi sur ton pc une
photo deana je faisais la même chose tu
veuxir à 3
de S avec me même temps
je pas sera vra pas ça veut dire quoi
pas de VO à cause de
moi option
seciv TER dev
[Musique]
cverite
j've ça devient bizarre quelle
souffrance moi il faut que je me tape le
même mec tous les mercredis soirs je
dois trancher je me dones jours pour
choisir et le meilleur gag j compte
[Musique]
bien je suis Doig sur la détente arrive
pas